Hannover ist Tabellenführer, die nächsten Trainerwechsel sind vollzogen und die 2. Liga ist mal wieder in Kuschellaune. Wir blicken mit Kölnexperte Jan Lukas Elskamp und Michael Fischer vom Fürther Flachpass und den Nürnberger Nachrichten auf die Liga im Generellen und schauen uns genauer an, was bei Köln und Fürth los ist. Viel Spaß! Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk. Ja, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe der Ligatour zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Ich bin Eva-Lotta Bohle und freue mich wirklich sehr, dass ich wieder gemeinsam mit tollen Gästen auf diese Liga schauen darf nach elf gespielten Spielen. Zum einen darf ich da an meiner Seite begrüßen Jan Lukas Elskamp, um– ja, du sprichst hier heute mit uns über den mehr oder weniger glorreichen FC Köln. Schön, dass du dabei bist.
Ja, schön, dass ich dabei sein darf. Und ich würde sagen, glorreich ist er immer.
Und dann freue ich mich auch sehr über Gast Nummer zwei, der gefühlt– sage ich schon seit Anfang der Saison, dass ich mich sehr darauf freue, dass er dann zuschließt. Hallo Michi, es tut mir ein bisschen leid, dass wir jetzt tatsächlich so viel zu reden haben.
Hallo ihr beiden. Danke für die Einladung, Eva. Und ich fühle mich ein bisschen wie so ein Krisenberichterstatter.
Auch schön. Bevor wir mit den Analysen starten, wie immer die Info. Der Rasenfunk hat keine Paywall. Er ist werbe- und sponsorenfrei und er wird nur durch euch finanziert. Ihr sorgt nicht nur dafür, dass wir unseren Gästen einen Honorar zahlen können, sondern dass auch Marc und ich die zweite Liga kapern durften. Und an der Stelle schon mal ein herzliches Dankeschön für die lieben Worte zu den letzten beiden Sendungen. Ohne euch als Community würde das alles ein bisschen weniger Spaß machen. Aber jetzt genug Housekeeping hier betrieben. Wir wollen reingehen in diese Sendung und das machen wir wie üblich mit einem kleinen Blick über die Liga und schauen mal, was da so los ist. Und ja, es ist sehr viel los, könnte man sagen. Ich habe es im Intro schon gesagt, Hannover führt diese Liga mit 22 Punkten an, hat aber auch nur 6 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Tabellenzehnten. Das ist der erste FC Kaiserslautern. Und einfach mal die Frage an dich, Jan Lukas, was überrascht dich denn momentan an dieser Liga am meisten?
Ja, also wir sind ja neu in der Liga, leider. Aber es ist ja nicht der schöne Aufstieg, sondern eher der nicht so schöne Abstieg in dem Fall gewesen. Man hat vorher immer gehört, ja, jeder kann da jeden schlagen. Und 2. Liga wusste man auch eh von den Stadien aus alten Tagen, dass es immer schöne Auswärtsfahrten waren. Wie ernst zu nehmen, dieses jeder kann jeden schlagen ist, das hört man zwar wahrscheinlich immer, wenn es um die 2. Liga geht. Aber ich finde es wirklich verrückt, wenn du aus der Bundesliga kommst, weißt du halt, bei sechs Spielen von neun am Wochenende, eh schon, wer gewinnt. In der 2. Liga würde ich bei keinem einzigen auf irgendwie sicher sagen können, wie wird das jetzt ausgehen. Und ja, das hat man zwar gehört so, aber das ist– und auch die Gegner stärken, wenn man die im Spiel gegen Köln sieht und dann einschätzen müsste, auf welchen Platz stehen die jetzt in der Tabelle. Das ist so durcheinander. Also manche Teams haben gegen den FC super gut gespielt, stehen aber irgendwie unten in der Tabelle. Andere Teams waren irgendwie, wo man dachte, boah, dass wir ausgerechnet gegen die jetzt nicht gewinnen. Und dann, weil die irgendwie total schwach waren, dann sind die aber gut, also es ist irgendwie sehr, sehr schwer einzuschätzen, finde ich.
Soll ich gleich weitermachen?
Ja, gerne.
Du hast vorhin Hannover 96 angesprochen, die hatte ich mir auch rausgeschrieben, denn Stefan Leitl war ja auch mal in Fürth, hat schon gezeigt, dass er aufsteigen kann. Und Hannover 96 hat ja mal ein 3-Jahres-Plan mit Stefan Leitl gehabt, der hat Martin Kind mal ausgerufen oder ganz Hannover ausgerufen. Und jetzt im dritten Jahr scheint man den tatsächlich erreichen zu können, nachdem Stefan Leitl schon mehrmals zur Disposition stand. Jetzt steht sie ganz oben und Stefan Leitl weiß, wie man aufsteigt in der 2. Liga. Vielleicht nicht zu unterschätzen, eine Erfahrung oder ein bisschen Erfahrung zu haben mit dieser Liga, wie Jan Lukas schon sagte. Sie ist schon ein bisschen tricky, die Liga. Und was es auch tricky macht, ich habe noch zwei andere Dinge hier stehen, Eva. Die Vollständigkeit. Sehr viele Spiele in der 2. Liga, leider berufsbedingt manchmal. Der 1. Liga zu Nürnberg ist eine Spitzenmannschaft jetzt. Das ist auch krass zu sehen, denn vor ein paar Wochen war da auch Miro Klose zur Disposition gestanden. Dann haben sie im Derby in Fürth 4-0 gewonnen. Jetzt gewinnen sie plötzlich ständig. Jetzt spielen sie den HSV im eigenen Stadion her, nachdem Robert Klaus mal gesagt hat, in der 2. Liga spielt niemand irgendwen her. Der Klub gewinnt fast beim HSV. Und Jan Regensburg, die 8 zu 3 beim 1. Liga zu Nürnberg verlieren oder 3 zu 8 aus Regensburgersicht, spielen zweimal zu Null. Unter anderem einmal gegen Fürth und gewinnen damit im Pokal. Und in der 2. Liga auch immer wieder. Also sehr verrückte 2. Liga.
Ja, auch die Torverhältnisse, würde ich sagen. Also, wenn man irgendwie guckt, Hannover hat 15 zu 7 Tore geschossen und kassiert und ist damit irgendwie erster Platz. Regensburg auf der anderen Seite hat 30 Tore kassiert, da waren nur 5 geschossen. Und alles dazwischen bewegt sich irgendwie zwischen Wahnsinn und extremen Wahnsinn. So extrem viele Mannschaften haben schon über 20 Tore geschossen und auch um die 20 kassiert. Also, es macht wirklich immer Spaß zuzuschauen, finde ich. Das ist wirklich, das ist doch, auch wenn du jetzt gerade für die VideozuschauerInnen etwas nicht so wirkst. Ich finde, ich, immer wenn ich mal reingucke, fallen Tore und gute Stimmung in den Stadion. Also, mir gefällt das.
Ja, ich muss tatsächlich sagen, was mich so am meisten überrascht hat, ist tatsächlich, wie Darmstadt unter Florian Kohfeldt performt. Michi wird jetzt kurz auch nochmal das Gesicht verziehen, weil sie waren quasi das letzte Opfer. Aber seit Kohfeldt da sind, sind sie seit 5 Spielen jetzt ungeschlagen. Nur eine Niederlage, 12 Punkte in 7 Spielen. Und eben stehen auch im Pokal Achtelfinale nach dem 3-2 Sieg in der Verlängerung gegen den Drittligisten Dynamo Dresden. Aber generell ist es schon krass, was sie dann doch jetzt für einen Schritt nach vorne gemacht haben. Und das hat mich durchaus, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich positiv sagen möchte, aber hat mich doch überrascht.
Ja, ich möchte kurz anmerken, ich verziehe auch mein Gesicht. Ich war vor ungefähr drei Wochen dran, als wir in Darmstadt fünf Tore kassiert haben.
Ach guck mal, das eint euch doch. Das ist doch auch schön. Das ist die große Anti-Darmstadt-Fraktion oder Darmstadt-Therapie, wie man sagen möchte.
Also ich fand sie sehr gut in Fürth. Ich bin keine Anti-Darmstadt-Fraktion. Es hat Spaß gemacht, zuzuschauen. Leider hat die andere Mannschaft nicht so viel Spaß gemacht in dem Spiel.
Guter Verlierer. Ich glaube, wir können noch ganz kurz ein Wort sagen. Kees van Wonderen hat weiterhin nicht seine Harry Potter-Fähigkeiten entdeckt. Ich glaube, ich kann nicht mehr erzählen, wie oft er jetzt gesagt hat, ich bin kein Harry Potter. Ja, Kees, wir haben es tatsächlich jetzt auch, glaube ich, alle verstanden. Da finde ich es tatsächlich, also mir fehlen da langsam auch wirklich die der Raum zum Witze drüber machen. Ich finde es tatsächlich tragisch, was bei Schalke passiert. Also aus meiner Sicht heraus, weil ich spiele auch nicht mit denen in einer Liga, noch nicht. Nächste Saison kommt dann, ja. Aber ich finde es also schon wirklich dramatisch, was da passiert. Da könnt ihr eigentlich tatsächlich alle zwei Wochen in Schalke Schwerpunkt hier setzen. Machen wir nicht, keine Angst. Aber ja, also da hat man gerade drüber gesprochen, dann kannst du direkt wieder darüber sprechen. Und ja, auch irgendwie finde ich auch krass, was auch in zwei Wochen einfach passieren kann. Also wenn wir auch auf Düsseldorf und den KSC schauen, beide jetzt Punkte liegen lassen, zwei miteinander verloren. Düsseldorf gegen Kaiserslautern und Münster und Karlsruhe gegen Hertha und Hannover. Also ja, da ist auch irgendwie ein bisschen wilde Zeiten angesagt. Habt ihr irgendwie irgendeinen Verein, wo ihr auf jeden Fall sagt, der könnte noch mal weiter oben reinrutschen oder der rutscht noch mal deutlich ab?
Ich wüsste jemanden, der abrutscht momentan, als ob das von der Leistungskurve, aber ich glaube, da kommen wir später noch mal drauf. Weil es ist nicht so gut ausführt, dass sich das jetzt plötzlich Preußen Münster und Jan Regensburg auch wieder spielen. Wenn man da immer den Blick nach hinten wirft und hofft, dass die da hinten mal nicht gewinnen, dann jetzt gewinnen auch die da hinten plötzlich wieder und holen ihre Punkte. Schalke macht es glücklicherweise eher selten. Ich habe Schalke ja vor zwei Wochen knapp live erleben dürfen. Das war auch schon, um vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen die Hörerinnen und Hörer auch mitzunehmen, schon tragisch. Ich war auf Schalke, das sind 60.000 Menschen im Stadion. Du spürst eine krasse Begeisterung in diesem Stadion. Die Menschen sind einfach immer noch stolz auf ihren Verein und dann werden sie von ihrer Mannschaft einfach so krass enttäuscht. Es stand ja zwischenzeitlich 4 1 für 4, das hätte 6 1 für 4 ausgehen können. Weil Fürth gerade auch nicht sonderlich stabil ist, ging es dann 3 zu 4 aus Schalkeer Sicht aus, aber trotzdem. Also 60.000 Menschen in den Stadion pilgern und wirklich so krass enttäuscht werden. Das hat mir schon fast Leid getan, auch wenn so Mitleid, glaube ich, das Schlimmste ist, was man bekommen kann.
Ja, ich hoffe, die andere Richtung Verein, der nochmal oben anklopfen darf, haben wir auch heute in der Sendung. Ansonsten bin ich da auch nicht der Mann für die Geheimtipps. Ich denke, das ist noch– noch habe ich da zu wenig gesehen. Ich schaue auch immer gerne Schalke aus Gründen des, ja, der großen Strahlkraft. Aber da haben wir ja jetzt gerade schon auch Worte zu verloren. Und das kann ich auch nicht anders wiedergeben. Ich war auch vor Ort und das war auch für lange Zeit oder gefühlt zumindest eins der größten Erfolgserlebnisse beim FC diese Saison. Und es ist ja schön, dass jeder irgendwie da mal so ein bisschen sich freuen darf.
Ja, eine Sache noch quasi zum Nachtragen bis hin zu den letzten beiden Sendungen. Wir haben immer wieder hier über die ganze Aktion rund um Karlsruhe gesprochen, um das Urteil da. Und letzte Woche kam dann eben auch das Urteil gegen die drei Fanprojekt-MitarbeiterInnen, die wurden zu Geldstrafen verurteilt. Mit dem Urteil folgte das Gericht teilweise der Forderung der Staatsanwaltschaft. Also sie sind nicht vorbestraft, weil es, ich glaube, unter 90 Tagessätze sind. Es gab dann auch sehr viele Soli-Bekundungen, jetzt auch zuletzt wieder in den Kurven der Nation. Und die Verteidigung hat auch angekündigt, in Berufen zu gehen. Und mache das immer einfach so, um gerne den anderen Arbeitgeber hier quasi so ein bisschen mit unterzubringen. Aber ich finde, es gibt tatsächlich ein sehr lesenswertes Interview mit Sophia Gershel vom Fanprojekt Karlsruhe. Da sind auch Stimmen vom Fanprojekt Bielefeld und quasi von der Gesamtvereinigung der Fanprojekte mit dabei. Das habe ich euch in den Show Notes verlinkt. Das ist ein Clubartikel, aber ich glaube, die ersten zehn, die auf den Link klinken, das ist so ein geschenkter Link. Die können das gerade lesen. Ganz toll. Ich habe die Tiefen des Internets entdeckt. Gut, dann lasse ich aber tatsächlich mal weitermachen und auf den 1. FC Köln schauen. Der, ja, mehr oder weniger gut in die Saison gestartet ist, lass uns uns so formulieren. Steht bei vier Siegen, drei Unentschieden und vier Niederlagen. Hat jetzt zuletzt im Pokal überzeugend gegen Kiel gewonnen und im Achtelfinale wartet passenderweise Hertha, gegen die man am Wochenende gerade auch gewinnen konnte. Man hat gemeinsam mit Darmstadt die drittbeste Offensive, aber eben auch nicht die beste Defensive, aber lass es mich so formulieren. Trainer ist seit Anfang der Saison der Österreicher Gerhard Struber. Der war vorher bei RB Salzburg unter anderen RB-Ablegern, also New York Red Bulls und FC Liefering. Jan Lukas, erzähl mir doch mal ein bisschen, wie spielt der FC unter Gerhard Struber und wie gefällt dir die Spielweise?
Also, wenn du mich das vor einer Woche gefragt hättest, hätte ich gesagt, ja, gar nichts, weil es ist dieses klassische RB-System zwar, aber nicht funktionabel. Der FC hat mit einer Viererkette gespielt und davor sind eigentlich alle immer auf den gegnerischen Beifühenden draufgelaufen, wirkte allerdings sehr unsystematisch. Jetzt weiß man aber in Köln, dass das letzten Endes so ein bisschen die dahinterliegende Idee von Christian Keller als Sportchef ist, der seine Trainer auch danach aussucht, im Prinzip. Das ist jetzt direkt ein Blick auf das große Ganze, aber die Idee ist es, aus dem FC ein Konzept oder das Konzept auf den FC zu übertragen, das ganzheitlich quasi bis in die älteren Jugendmannschaften, in die Frauenteams, alle eben so eine, ja, man muss ja fast schon sagen, Rasenball-ähnliche Pressing-Philosophie gefahren wird. Die Idee war, glaube ich, dass man gemerkt hat, dass die Baumgart-Spielidee ganz gut funktioniert hat. Und dann hat man eben davon ausgehend gesagt, okay, wir wollen ein Verein sein, der dafür steht, hohe Ballgewinne zu erzielen. Man will, ja, man will den Weg zum Tor nach Balleroberung möglichst kurz haben. Und dann hat man sich eben zusammengesetzt mit den verschiedensten Abteilungen. Und das, was sie nach außen sagen, ist immer, wenn man auf einen Sportplatz kommt und die haben keine Trikots an, dann soll man sofort sehen, welche Mannschaft ist der 1. FC Köln. So heißt, alle spielen ähnlich. Das Problem ist, dass man hat jetzt zwar einen Trainer danach verpflichtet und man hat auch den Saisonstart passabel gemeistert. Also man hatte relativ viele überlegene Spiele. Es war relativ begeisternd. Auch wenn dann gegen den HSV und gegen Magdeburg gab es bitterere Heimspiele, nicht so richtig die Ergebnisse gefolgt sind. Dann gab es aber so einen kleinen Bruch nach einer Länderspielpause, was glaube ich nach dem Sieg gegen Ulm noch extrem war. Dieses Darmstadt-Spiel, wo man wirklich fünf Tore kassiert hat und wo im Nachhinein auch Florian Kohfeldt gesagt hat, wir wissen mittlerweile, wie der FC spielt. Wir wissen, wie wir diese Pressing-Trigger, wie Struber immer sagt, umspielen können. Und ja, das Blöde ist, dass es gegen Paderborn einfach exakt das Gleiche war und man als Fan das Gefühl hatte, ja, okay, selbst wir wissen, wie man uns ausspielt. Dazu gehört halt auch eine sehr schwache, personelle Außenverteidigung zumindest. Zumindest defensiv gesehen mit Jan Thielmann, der das durch Transfersperre gezwungen als Rechtsverteidiger oder Rechtsverteidiger lösen muss. Parker Rade hat seine Stärken auch ganz klar vorne. Und so war es eben dieses 4-2-2-2, manchmal auch ein bisschen anders gestaffelt, aber auf jeden Fall ein vorne anlaufen, was eben nach wenigen Wochen entschlüsselt wurde. Und man dachte quasi, okay, jetzt warten wir eigentlich nur noch darauf, dass die nächsten Gegners auch entschlüsseln und dann müssen wir uns wieder umorientieren. Dann gab es eben besagtes Geheimtraining vor dem Spiel gegen Kiel im Pokal. Und so richtig viel hat sich noch nicht geändert, außer dass man zu Null gespielt hat und dass es einfach ein sehr, sehr defensiverer Ansatz war, dass man nicht mehr so hoch draufgegangen ist. Das war das Spiel gegen Paderborn in der Liga, da ist man sehr defensiv gestanden, hat aber noch die Viererkette gespielt. Und gegen Kiel im Pokal war es dann so, dass die Dreierkette ausgepackt wurde, dass Marvin Schwebel im Tor stand. Und ja, es war deutlich, deutlich weniger attraktiv von der Grundausrichtung, aber es war endlich mal so ein bisschen Sicherheit, die im Fokus stand. Und das gab es halt vorher gar nicht. Und deswegen gefällt das, weil man eben diesen starken Kontrast zuvor hatte, doch mir auch wieder etwas besser. Und man denkt zumindest wieder, okay, man kann auch reagieren, man ist nicht wie wirklich sehr viele Spielteile vorher extrem ausreichend war. Und ja, sodass man jetzt vielleicht doch wieder ein bisschen Fünktchen Hoffnung hat, was so Flexibilität angeht.
Du hast Schwebe eben schon mal angesprochen. Also, vorher hatte ja Urbig eigentlich die 10 Spiele davor gemacht. Ist Michi ja auch noch ein Begriff, wo er in seiner Zeitball führt. Also, Struber hat es eben jetzt gesagt, dass er Schwebe jetzt eher im Tor sieht. Findest du, das ist ja irgendwie eine unnötige Diskussion, die man aufmacht. Findest du, ist das gerechtfertigt, dass man Urbig da jetzt wieder zurückstellt?
Ich persönlich habe auch immer viele Jugendspiele gesehen. Es gab auch mal so Youth League, Qualifikationsspielen Großes, wo man sich eben als starke Jugendmannschaft in Deutschland für qualifiziert hatte. Hab dementsprechend Junos Urbig schon lange, lange gesehen. Und es war eigentlich immer klar und auch jedem im Verein klar, dass es ein Ausnahmetalent, der wird früher oder später den Profis im Tor stehen. Und dementsprechend habe ich natürlich auch gewisse Sympathien, wenn man jemanden so lange irgendwie begleitet und weiß, okay, der hat sich wirklich so stark entwickelt. Hab dann auch gerne mal letztes Jahr Fürth geschaut, war ja auch Lämpere ausgeliehen. Ja, ich weiß nicht, hat mir eigentlich immer relativ gut gefallen, auch wenn es wechselhaft war, aber da kommen wir ja später zu. Urbigs selbst habe ich mich sehr viel gefreut, dass er jetzt eben das Vertrauen bekommen hat. Zumal es eben im Sommer auch sehr unklar war, was ist jetzt mit Marvin Schwäbe. Es war unter der Hand, beziehungsweise ohne, dass ich jetzt irgendwelche Infos hätte, die geheim sind, aber es war mit mehr oder weniger jedem klar, der FC weiß, dass er Urbigs zurückbekommt, weiß, dass er in die 2. Liga abgestiegen ist und dass sie auf junge Spieler setzen wollen. Dementsprechend ist es für mich gar nicht so entscheidend, wollte jetzt unbedingt als erstes Schwäbe weg oder wollte der Verein ihn weghaben, das klingt jetzt so hart, aber wollte der Verein ihn ruhig auch, wäre es okay für den Verein, ihn zu verkaufen. Man hat sich, glaube ich, intern sehr früh auf Urbeck als Nummer 1 festgelegt und dann ist davon ausgegangen, weil Schwäbe sehr gute letzte Saison ausgespielt hat, dass man den schon irgendwie für eine okaye Summe verkauft bekommt. Das hat halt leider, wie wir jetzt wissen, nicht funktioniert. Damit hatte man eben die sehr ungünstige Situation, was macht man jetzt? Nimmt man den wahrscheinlich noch etwas stärkeren Schwäbe, der auch schon sehr viel Erfahrung hat, jetzt ist immer das große Plusargument, was alle pro Schwäbe-Leute haben, ist halt Ruhe ausstrahlen, wobei man da auch reden kann. Das ist auch im Pokal unter einer Flanke sehr schön durchgelaufen. Hätte auch blöd ausgehen können, aber das sind so halt die Punkte, die für Schwäbe jetzt sprechen. Oder setzt man eben auf Urbik. Und vor der Saison hieß es ja auch im Pokal spielt Urbik, hat auch in der ersten Pokalrunde gespielt. Wir wollen ihn stärken, es geht Leistungsprinzip und wir sehen ihn als Nummer eins. Weiß nicht, ob man sich da nicht so ein bisschen in die Tasche gelogen hat und dieses Leistungsprinzip, ob das als Wort dann wirklich so stimmt. Ja, jetzt ist auf einmal das Leistungsprinzip pro Schwäbe, ist man sich natürlich irgendwo treu geblieben. Das Problem daran ist, dass der FC Magzor viele Tore kassiert haben, das lag aber halt nicht ab Torwart. Also es gab einen, der war genau das erste Saisontor gegen den HSV nach etwa drei Minuten, wo man halt– also ich nicht, ich habe den Jungen ja viel gesehen– aber denken könnte, oh Gott, das ist jetzt unser Torwart, der lässt den Ball direkt zum Stürmer abprallen und der HSV führt nach drei Minuten. Sonst hat er sich aber nicht zu Schulden kommen lassen. Es hat auch wenig Unhaltbare rausgeholt, abseits von Testspielen, wo er eigentlich mal sehr gut gespielt hat. Ja, also er hat sich jetzt nichts groß zu Schulden kommen lassen und es ist natürlich so, dass man einen jungen Spieler eigentlich auch stärken will. Jetzt ist beim FC genau dieser Zwiespalt. Okay, will man jetzt super schnell aufsteigen? Will man dieses Jahr aufsteigen? Offizielle Aussage ist, man will schnellstmöglich aufsteigen, was irgendwo impliziert, dass es dieses Jahr sein soll, ohne aber den Spielern Druck zu machen. Wenn man jetzt klar sagt, ja, wir müssen dieses Jahr unbedingt aufsteigen, dann wäre, glaube ich, das Verständnis auch etwas größer, Schwäbe aufzustellen. So ist aber die Aussage, wir wollen schnellstmöglich aufsteigen, und dabei etwas entwickeln. Und da, finde ich, kann man eigentlich nicht nach zehn Spieltagen einen jungen Spieler anzählen. Jetzt ist blöderweise beim NFC das zweite grundlegende Thema, die Vertragskonstellation, was eigentlich ungefähr jeden jungen Spieler angeht. URBIG hat– also, die werden mittlerweile auch gar nicht mehr veröffentlicht, die Vertragslaufzeiten. Bei URBIG ist das aber noch so alt, dass man es halt noch weiß. Und der Vertrag läuft nicht dieses Jahr aus, aber die danach. Heißt, man will eigentlich, wenn man weiß, er möchte nächstes Jahr Bundesliga spielen, muss man ihn nach dieser Saison höchstwahrscheinlich verkaufen, weil Verlängern beim FC ist dann wahrscheinlich schwierig. So, und das muss man aber dann auch sagen. Ja gut, fördern wir jetzt den Spieler, um ihn dann im Sommer nicht wirklich teuer verkaufen zu können. Andererseits motiviert man auch keinen Spieler, einen Vertrag zu verlängern, wenn man sagt, ja gut, du bist aber jetzt bei uns die Nummer 2 und wir degradieren dich hier gerade öffentlich. Also, das ist eine sehr schwere Konstellation. Ich bin immer pro junge Leute eigentlich, aber ich verstehe auch, dass man sagt, ja gut, wenn du dich nicht binden willst an den Verein, und du bist halt sportlich vielleicht noch knapp die Nummer 2. Und Schwäbe würde auch sagen, er bleibt noch länger und lange, was natürlich auch die andere Frage ist. So, dann kann ich zumindest den Gedanken verstehen. Aber ich halte nichts eigentlich von diesem Jahr, wir lassen dich erst spielen, weil das ist bei dem FC immer so, auch mit Downs damals so gewesen, nicht Downs, mit Diehl damals so gewesen, der jetzt in Stuttgart spielt. Du spielst erst in der Abstiegssaison, wo man wirklich kaum offensive Leute hatte, wo vielleicht noch ein frischer Impuls geholfen hätte. Du spielst erst, wenn du verlängert hast. Jetzt haben wir Marwin Obus. Ja, du spielst erst, wenn du verlängert hast. Der hat auch einen auslaufenden Vertrag. Ja, aber irgendwie in so einer Stimmung verlängert halt keiner so gerne. Also das ist so ein bisschen, man will es lösen, aber macht es dadurch schlimmer.
Vor allem sollte man am Ende der Saison auch steigen und dann eigentlich sagen, wir würden gerne ein paar eigene Talente mitnehmen und die sind dann alle schon weg. Das ist auch günstig. Es gibt ja auch zum Beispiel, du hast einmal ganz kurz Tim Lämpeler angesprochen. Ja, sicherlich bis jetzt mit so ein bisschen der MVP der Köln-Saison könnte man auf jeden Fall offensiv sagen, also fünf Tore, neun Scorer-Punkte. Generell die Offensive von Köln, wenn man nach den XG-Werten geht. Ich bin da zwar immer so ein bisschen vorsichtig, aber ich habe da trotzdem mal ein bisschen draufgeguckt. Also nur Jan Regensburg, anders performt mehr. Also Regensburg sollte eigentlich rund um die 13 Tore haben. Wir haben es eben schon mal gesagt, sie haben fünf. Und Köln hätte eigentlich die beste Offensive, weil sie hätten fast 28 Tore schießen sollen. Man steht jetzt bei 23, also das ist immer noch nicht schlecht. Aber es zeigt ja auch, also es ist ja durchaus Potenzial nach vorne da und man nutzt ja trotzdem viele Chancen. Aber wie siehst du Tim Lämpere in der Konstellation? Also wenn du jetzt schon sagst, so richtig attraktiv ist man nicht für Jugendspieler. Also beziehungsweise man, was heißt nicht attraktiv, aber die Art und Weise, wie man mit ihnen umgeht in der Vertragskonstellation ist vielleicht nicht die beste Art und Weise.
Ja, genau. Also die Vertragskonstellation bei Tim Lämpere ist so, dass der Vertrag zu Säulein ausläuft, heißt, im besten Fall steigt man nicht auf, er spielt eine gute Saison und er ist trotzdem weg, ohne dass man irgendwas davon hat. Und jetzt ist bei Lämpere nochmal die Sondersituation, dass er halt bei Roger Wittmann bei Rogon unter Vertrag steht, wo er der Letzte im Kader ist. Ja, da werden schon kritisch die Mundwinkel zusammengezogen. Das ist kein gutes Zeichen, wenn man einen jungen Spieler entwickeln will, wie man so weiß. Und der FC hat nach der Just-in-Deal-Thematik auch, die schon wirklich jahrelang hier geht, gesagt, dass man eigentlich mit dem man nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten will. Jetzt ist doberweise Lämpere oder zum Glück ist er der Letzte, aber er ist eben auch noch der Letzte, der eben dort unter Vertrag steht. Und man halt immer weiß, ja gut, a ist da der Draht nach Hoffenheim sehr kurz, b ist da generell der Draht zu Gutzahlen und Vereinen, auch besonders gerne gesehen. Und da ist dann halt auch wieder die Frage, inwieweit kann man das in einer sportlichen Führung vorwerfen, dass er dann so einen Vertrag nicht verlängert bekommt. Andererseits ist es jetzt auch nicht so, dass er es zu dieser Saison überraschenderweise, oh, Tim Lämpere kommt zurück, den haben wir ja vergessen entführt. Den gibt es ja auch noch, sondern es war relativ klar, auf den wird man setzen, weil man ja keine Spieler kaufen konnte. Also in weiser Voraussicht eine Kaderplanung durchzuführen, hätte wahrscheinlich impliziert, solche Verträge dann zu verlängern und zu sagen, ja, du bist unser Stürmer, ja, wir setzen auf dich, wir wollen dich fördern, ebenso im Tor. Aber dann verlängert doch gerne den Vertrag, wir zahlen dir auch von mir aus hohe Punktprämien oder Einsatzprämien, wir wollen dich auch wirklich fördern, wir können keinen anderen spielen. Ich habe jetzt logischerweise keinen Sportdirektor, aber ich habe auch keine Erfahrung. Klingt hier viel zu detailliert. Aber generell möchte man ja, oder war man in der Situation, viel Vorschuss geben zu können, dann ein kleines bisschen Vertragscommitment, denke ich, müsste man dann irgendwo auch einfordern können. Jetzt muss ich aber glücklicherweise auch nicht mit diesen Beratergestalten mich abgeben. Aber es ist irgendwo in der Planung schon ein bisschen seltsam zu sagen, ja, das ist unser Stürmer, wir möchten den entwickeln. Ja, ups, der hat aber einen Vertrag, der nur bis zum Saisonende geht, weil eigentlich ist es ja das Best Case. Der spielt gut und der freut sich auch für einen FC zu spielen. Wirkt zumindest so, kann ich natürlich wieder so genau nicht sagen, aber besser hätte es ja nicht laufen können als eine gute Leistung. So und dann ist aber jetzt so, ja, oh, jetzt ist das Best Case eingetreten, darauf sind wir ja nicht vorbereitet. Also weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt irgendwie so eine sinnvolle Planung dann ist.
Michi guckt auch sehr skeptisch. Lemberle und Urwich ja auch zwei Spieler, Jan Lukas hat es eben schon gesagt, die ja auch bei Fürth waren. Wie schaust du da von außen drauf? Also findest du das auch etwas fragwürdig vielleicht, um es so auszudrücken?
Boah, das vermag ich gar nicht zu beurteilen, ob es fragwürdig ist, aber man sieht zum Beispiel bei Tim Lemberle, was bei so jungen Spielern oder jungen Stürmern das zweite Jahr auch ausmacht. Das war zum Beispiel Uragna Ache war in Fürth ja auch mal. Hat dann auch im zweiten Jahr und jetzt im dritten Jahr dann sehr gut performt. Also ich hätte ihn gerne in diesem Jahr noch gesehen. Wir kommen auch später noch mal ein kleiner Spoiler auf Tim Lemberle, weil er für das System Zorniger vielleicht ein ganz wichtiger Spieler war, weil er ja ganz ähnlich spielen lassen wollte wie Gerhard Stuban, wie der erste FC Köln. Insofern habe ich natürlich immer einen Blick drauf. Ich habe auch einen Blick drauf. Auch da nochmal ein Spoiler am Wochenende. Er spielt ja in Köln gegen Fürth. Das wäre natürlich wieder eine wunderbare Entschließung.
Alles geplant hier.
Tim Plemperle. Der in Fürth teilweise schon Tim Verplemperle genannt wurde von manchen, weil er sehr viele Chancen vergeben hat, der jetzt plötzlich der Topscorer der 2. Liga ist. Letztes Jahr hätte es in Fürth auch schon sein können anhand der Chancenqualität, die er hatte. Aber ja, wie ich gerade schon sagte, das ist das zweite Jahr oft. Die Spieler müssen sich erst mal akklimatisieren auf diesem Niveau. Ich verstehe es bei Jonas Uebig einfach nicht. Ich habe es noch im letzten Jahr im Ohr. Ich glaube, es war im Januar, als Lukas Quassenjog was sagte, das ist der zukünftige Nationaltorhüter. Klar, wenn man einen zukünftigen Nationaltorhüter im Kader hat, sollte man ihn wahrscheinlich auch spielen lassen, weil er ja auch schon mehrfach nachgewiesen hat, auch in der zweiten Liga nachgewiesen hat. Er war ja Vorführer auch schon in Regensburg. Und in Regensburg hat er auch gute Leistungen gebracht. Es war dieses halbe Jahr, dass es ihm Jonas Uebig extrem gut getan hat, schon da zu spielen. Jetzt hat man in Fürth dann gesehen, dass er schon ein halbes Jahr weiter ist als ein typischer Jugendtorhüter. Und ich fand, dass er die krassen Fehler gemacht hat. Ja, vorhin angesprochen, am ersten Spieltag hat er diesen krassen Fehler gemacht. Hat auch Tim Lämpeler am ersten Spieltag eine krasse Chance vergeben. Also das passt auch bei beiden zusammen gegen den HSV. Aber es sind junge Spieler, die machen Fehler. Man sagt ja immer, man setzt auf junge Spieler und lässt sie Fehler machen. Und dann machen sie einen Fehler und sind vielleicht nicht auf dem Niveau von Jonas Uebig letztes Jahr. Also das Spiel in Paderborn, Eva Freundi Expected Goals erwähnt hat, hat damals Paderborn vier Expected Goals on target, also sie hätten vier Tore schießen müssen. Und das Spiel ging zu Null aus für Fürth. Also Uebig hat einfach vier Tore gerettet in diesem Spiel, in einem Spiel. Das zeigt ja schon, was sein maximales Leistungsvermögen ist. Und das hebt man natürlich nicht gerade, wenn er auf der Bank sitzt. Noch dazu habe ich Jonas Uebig als einen sehr selbstbewussten Menschen kennengelernt. Ich glaube, er nennt das selbstbewusst und professionell, ist vielleicht die richtige Bezeichnung. Er nennt das professionell auf, aber es wird ihn extrem, extrem kränken. Und natürlich wird er danach dann gehen, wenn das so weitergeht. Die Frage ist, wohin. Ob er jetzt unbedingt zu den Bayern wechseln muss, glaube ich jetzt nicht. Aber so ein Zwischenstep wäre vielleicht nochmal ganz gut.
Jan Lukas, lass uns noch mal kurz drauf schauen, weil wir haben jetzt schon ein bisschen über die Offensive gesprochen. Du hast gesagt, naja, an den– also an Uebig lag es nicht, dass die Gegendrohre gekommen sind. Lass doch noch mal kurz drauf gucken, woran liegt es denn dann? Also, weil es gibt sowohl das 5-1 gegen Darmstadt, es gab, wie ich auch fand, dieses absolute Freak-Spiel gegen Karlsruhe, was am Ende 4-4 ausgeht. Das haben wir hier mit einem Karlsruher Experten besprochen, der dann, glaube ich, der glückliche Raar am Ende war, weil man führt eigentlich 3-0, oder mehr oder weniger glücklich, glaube ich, am Ende waren beide einfach froh, als die 90 Minuten vorbei waren und keiner einen Herzinfarkt hatte. Na ja, also man führt eigentlich 3-0 und vergisst dann, irgendwie komplett zu verteidigen. Also wie kommen aus deiner Sicht diese 5-1 Liederlage gegen Darmstadt, dieses 4-4 gegen Karlsruhe, wie guckst du da drauf? Wie machst du da die Probleme fest?
Ich habe es mir gerade auch noch mal aufgemacht. Bis zu diesem Karlsruhe-Spiel gab es sechs Spiele vorher in der Liga, wo mit einer Ausnahme immer ein Tor kassiert wurde und viermal auch mindestens zwei. Also zum Start zwei gegen HSV, dann zwei gegen Elbersberg, dann im Pokal zwei gegen Sandhausen, dann mal zu Null gegen Braunschweig und zu Eins gegen Schalke, dann wieder zwei gegen Magdeburg, zwei gegen Düsseldorf, vier gegen Karlsruhe. Also das ist dieser Start, den ich meinte, wo man wirklich wusste, okay, also jeder hat gecheckt, wie man gegen den FC spielt. Dann kurze Zeit zu Null gegen Ulm, die aber seit der zehn Minuten in Unterzahl waren. Und dann eben fünf gegen Darmstadt und wieder zwei gegen Paderborn. Also zu dem Zeitpunkt sah es auch so aus, als wäre es quasi schon beschlossene Sache, dass man eben den Fürth-Move machen muss und Sportchef, der eben am Trainer hängt, mitsamt Trainer vor die Tür setzen. Das ist wahrscheinlich einem ziemlich trägen Präsidium in Köln geschuldet, was eh nach einer Mitgliederversammlung, in dem es das Vertrauen mehr oder weniger entzogen bekommen hat, etwas beleidigt oder schmollend auf den Verein zu blicken scheint. Also es wirkte quasi schon, nicht wirklich beschlossene Sache, aber dann gab es auch schon, ja, in der Schublade liegt der Funkelplan, wo es dann hieß, Freetail Funkel übernimmt, bis ein neuer Trainer gefunden wurde. Da haben die Kieler sich schon aufgeregt, weil die damals ja schon mal unter dem Funkelplan in der Relegation gelitten hatten. Und es sah eben alles danach aus, okay, das Pokalspiel kriegt Funkel schon, und man sucht dann irgendwie in Ruhe mit einem neuen Sportchef, mit einem neuen Trainer. Und dann kam eben diese Umstellung gegen Kiel mit Fünferkette, wo man sich dann auch, manche sagen, Stuber wollte sich dann, als es um den Job ging, von der kellerischen Idee so ein bisschen lösen und hat gesagt, ey, wenn es hier gerade um meinen Job geht, dann mache ich jetzt mal, was ich denke. Halte ich ehrlich gesagt für ein bisschen weit hergeholt, so weil ich glaube nicht, dass man sich als Trainer in der 2.Bundesliga so krass von einem Sportchef reinreden lassen muss. Weiß man natürlich nicht. Auf jeden Fall ist das Entscheidende. Gegen Kiel wurde die Fünferkette ausgepackt und gegen Kiel wurde deshalb nicht, wegen eines Torwartwechsels oder so, Schwäbe hatte kaum etwas zu tun. Man stand viel sicherer und man hat dann die Null gehalten. Jetzt hat man gegen die Hertha die Null gehalten, was natürlich im Spiel ist auch immer viel Matchglück, das wissen wir alle. Das kann auch, wenn ein Tor mal nicht gegeben wird zum 1-0 gegen Kiel oder wenn ein Ball mal, wo Schwäbe drunter durchläuft, als Halbfeldflanke und die Hertha das Tor macht, kann das auch anders aussehen. Dann ist wahrscheinlich ein anderes Szenario für den ganzen Verein eingetreten. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass die Stimmung etwas umgeschwankt ist zu haben wir jetzt eine Lösung gefunden? Ist das jetzt the way to go? Man hat eben jetzt, also in meinen Augen, gerade auch mit dem Blick auf Hannover, vorher war es Düsseldorf, man hat in der 2. Liga schon ein bisschen den Luxus, dass man auch aus einer stabilen Defensive immer noch mit ein bisschen individueller Klasse zu Chancen kommt. Also ich glaube nicht, dass man den Fußball neu erfinden muss, um mit dem Kader, wie der FC ihn hat, aufsteigen zu können oder zumindest mal oben mitzuspielen. So, wenn man das jetzt erkannt hat, dann war es vielleicht allerhöchste Eisenbahn. Ob das dann jetzt wirklich rechtzeitig war oder ob man doch besser jetzt den Cut gemacht hätte und mit einem anderen Gespannen, das eben auch hätte anders umsetzen können, werden wir jetzt nie erfahren, weil es eben nicht so gekommen ist. Der Trend ist in dem Fall der Friend so. Ja, und mehr werden jetzt die nächsten Wochen zeigen. Fürth scheint ja erstmal auch noch ein Gegner zu sein, wo man die Trendwende eher fortsetzen kann, aber da würde ich auch aus FC-Fern nie so sicher sprechen, weil a. baut man auch gerne mal andere auf, andererseits ist das nochmal ein Doppeltes Ausrufezeichen für Punkt A. Also es kann immer so viel passieren.
Ja, also ich glaube halt schon, dass man spätestens in der Winterpause nochmal drauf guckt auf die Hinrunde. Ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt, diese– ich weiß, man sagt es jede Saison, aber diese Liga ist extrem nah beieinander. Ich habe es eben nicht gesagt, aber der FC Köln ist auf Platz 11 und er ist fünf Punkte entfernt von den zwei platzierten SC Paderborn. Fünf Punkte. Es haben drei Vereine, glaube ich, 17 Punkte. Es ist wirklich super nah alles beieinander. Das heißt, nach zwei Spieltagen kann aus einem Abschiebskandidat ein halber Auschiebskandidat werden. Wir haben es bei Nürnberg eben gesehen. Michi hat es angesprochen. Ja, sag auch gerne erst, Michi.
Fürth ist auch nur zwei Punkte hinter dem 1. FC Köln. Könnte am Wochenende am 1. FC Köln vorbeiziehen, weil wir gerade schon so negativ über Fürth sprechen. Also das spricht nochmal und untermauert eine These.
Ja, aber das ist es ja tatsächlich. Ich finde, es klingt wirklich immer wie so ein ich werfe denn hier gleich einfach drei Euro ins Phrasenschwein, aber es ist halt wirklich, nach zwei Wochen kann diese Liga immer komplett anders aussehen und ich glaube, das macht es eben so schwierig auch, manchmal ohne da jetzt irgendwie die Vereinführung vom FC Köln auch in Schutz zu nehmen, aber es ist halt schwierig irgendwie, also weil man es eben sieht. Man sieht es bei Darmstadt, man sieht es eben aber auch bei zum Beispiel FC Nürnberg und KOE, dass eben zwei Wochen später kann die Welt schon wieder anders aussehen und das geht halt. Das Wichtigste ist halt einfach, dass du eine Konstanz entwickelst und das hat Hannover halt zum Beispiel einfach geschaffen, indem sie eben ja eigentlich nie mehr als ein Spiel verlieren und da immer direkt zurück, also irgendwie immer zurückkommen und ich glaube tatsächlich, und das ist jede Saison richtig, aber ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es diese Saison nochmal ganz anders wird, weil eben einfach von den Namen, die in dieser Liga spielen, es nochmal um einiges näher zusammen ist und ich glaube, dass also die nächsten Gegner für Köln, wir haben es jetzt ungefähr 8.000 Mal gesagt, es führt zu Hause, dann spielt man auswärts bei Preußen Münster, die gerade vor Thuner Düsseldorf geschlagen haben, und dann geht es zu Hause gegen Hannover und das ist irgendwie schon so ein wildes Potpourri von den Vereinen, gegen die man spielt und ich glaube, spätestens nach dem Hannover Spiel, wenn man wirklich, glaube ich, in dieser oberen Riege dazugehören will, dann muss man dieses Hannover Spiel, darf man nicht verlieren, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, du klingst auch irgendwo ein bisschen Präsidial, würde ich fast schon sagen, weil genau das hören wir hier die ganze Zeit mit Konstanz und Konstanz und ich bin auch, ich war lange ein sehr, sehr großer Keller-Fan, weil ich ihn für einen sehr klugen Mann halte und für einen nachhaltigen Manager. Problem ist, Konstanz macht halt, in erster Linie kann man auch bei Manchester United nachfragen, dann sind, wenn du auch wirklich überzeugt bist, dass es auch die richtigen Leute sind. Und beim FC steht man jetzt vor einem der wichtigsten Transferwinter, wo man halt nach 18 Monaten mal wieder Spieler verpflichten darf. Und da ist halt schon eine sehr große Ausrichtungsfrage, überlässt man das, also glaubt man noch genug an Keller, ohne dass man ihn in der nächsten Krise dann doch vor die Tür setzen würde. Und die eigentlich sinnvolle Variante, bis zum Winter warten und dann mal gucken, ist halt eigentlich zu spät, weil jetzt muss man, ist eh schon hoffentlich, also groß ist hoffentlich, vorbereitet worden, sehr lange Zeit, was wird diesen Winter passieren? Auch das ist jetzt wieder so ein bisschen umgeworfen, ja spielt man jetzt plötzlich Fünferkette, so brauchst du wieder ganz andere Leute. So was ist jetzt wirklich die langfristige Idee? Gibt es mit diesem Personal eine langfristige Idee? Und nach der muss man dann halt entweder diese Leute, nach dieser Idee, welche auch immer dann die ist, auf die man sich festlegt, nach der muss man dann eben eigentlich jetzt schon vorbereiten und das Transferfenster gestalten. Wie du sagst, es ist aber halt einfach sehr schwer, weil man möglicherweise auch mit diesem Konstanzgedanken, und der ist natürlich handelnden Personen immer lieber, weil sie die handelnden Personen unter sich eingestellt haben, wenn man da eben dran hängt. Das ist letztendlich das riesige Fragezeichen, wo man diese Transfer-Sperre jetzt noch einmal mit einbringen musste, weil das ja wirklich eine Ausnahmesituation ist. Ist jetzt Keller der Mann, dem man sagt, okay, wir glauben noch an deine Idee, obwohl man eben so weit unten stand, obwohl die zweite Mannschaft lange wenig erfolgreich war, obwohl die U19 teilweise dieses Jahr wenig erfolgreich war, was alles auch mit der Transfer-Sperre zu tun hat, weil du einfach Beine verloren hast, die nicht ersetzt werden konnten. Jetzt sind die Frauen blöderweise auch die ganze Zeit schlecht nach dieser Spielidee. Also, die Vertragskonstellationen gefallen mir nicht. Die zweite Frau, wen das interessiert, die spielen mit unserem Verein, wo ich selber auch Trainer bin, in der dritten Liga, Frauen. Und sind da auch auf einem nahen Abstiegsplatz. Also, es gab eine Phase vor zwei Wochen, wo man dachte oder ich auch dachte, okay, Keller nachhaltiger Manager, aber was spricht noch dafür? Die Transfers würde ich ihn gar nicht so viel kritisieren, weil es war schwer, auch vorher. Scheiß finanzielle Lage. Die Vertragssituationen sind aber auch mies. Die Trainer-Anstellungen waren mit Timo Schulz, ja, okay, kann man irgendwie nicht so viel sagen, hat halt ganz schwere Situationen nach Baum gehabt. Gerhard Stuber, der sich zu verrennen schien in den ersten Wochen mit seinem System. Ist das wirklich jetzt die Zukunft, auf die man diesen Verein aufbaut, wo man dieses so, ich kann es nur nochmal betonen, so wichtige Transferfenster in seine Hände legt? Ja oder nein? Und man muss auch das nochmal sagen, im Hintergrund, die finanzielle Lage hat sich deutlich verbessert. Man hat jetzt auch einen gewissen Handlungsspielraum und das ist sicherlich auch auf Management zu, also man darf jetzt nicht nur die negativen Sachen ansprechen. Das war gute Arbeit, die vor allem natürlich im Finanzbereich geleistet wurde, aber auch einhergehend natürlich mit sportlichen Entscheidungen. Wenn man rein aufs Sportliche guckt, muss man aber halt sagen, gut, da war jetzt auch sehr viel daneben gegriffen. Ich kann verstehen, wenn Vorstand zum Schluss kommt, ja, okay, das ist endlich mal nachhaltig. Eva Bohle sagt auch Konstanz, Konstanz, so. Dann vertrauen wir mal auf ihre kompetente Sichtweise. Dann bist du auch am Ende schuld.
Ja, klar, ne, bin ich super.
Ja, ich glaube, das Präsidium vom FC Köln ist froh, wenn sie einfach gar keine Schuld haben, wenn die einfach so durch sich lawinern. Und dann war halt Eva-Lotta, ich weiß nicht, ob aus Bielefeld, aber ich glaube schon, schuld ist. So, das ist, glaube ich, da wären sie fein mit. So, das ist halt irgendwie auch die nächste, nächstgrößere Stellschraube, die würde jetzt am Rahmen sprengen. Ich denke, die Grundsituation ist jetzt halbwegs deutlich geworden.
Ich glaube, der FC muss einfach aussteigen, damit man wieder komplette Schwerpunkte über so eine Stunde basteln kann, um alles zu erklären. Aber lasst uns doch tatsächlich, also erstmal vielen lieben Dank an Lukas. Ich glaube, das war sehr ausführlich und sehr klar einmal beschrieben, was ist denn eigentlich beim FC los. Und wir wissen jetzt alle, die Transferphase im Winter, das wird spannend. Das wird besser als die Staffelfinale von Game of Thrones. Keine Ahnung, nie gesehen. Aber ich habe gehört, das war nicht so gut. Und dann hat Jan Lukas eben im Vorgespräch gesagt, er ist sehr gespannt auf die Spielvereinigung führt. Und Michi, über genau die wollen wir jetzt sprechen. Denn da war einiges los in den letzten Wochen. Man ist auf Platz 13, hat 13 Punkte, hat drei Siege, vier Unentschieden, vier Niederlagen. Und Alex Sorniger, der musste nach der Derby-Niederlage oder nach der Derby-Schmach gehen, gemeinsam mit Rashid Azusi. Der war sehr lange im Verein, also zuletzt, glaube ich, jetzt über längere Zeit, seit 2017 als Sportdirektor, war, glaube ich, schon mal 2008 als sportlicher Leiter tätig. Und momentan ist Leonard Haas, der Interimstrainer. Es sah erst gut aus, es kam dies 4 zu 3 auf Schalke, aber dann eben– scheint, Trend is your Friend– eine 1 zu 5-Niederlage gegen Darmstadt am Wochenende und natürlich noch unter der Woche das Pokal aus in Regensburg, trotz langer Überzahl. Michi, wo möchtest du gerne bei Fürth anfangen?
Puh, das ist ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz schwierig. Vielleicht kurz zu rasch wieder zu sich nochmal. Also er war ja als Spieler hier, es wird immer überstrapaziert, aber er war 22 Jahre mit Unterbrechungen im Verein. Also der kam 1997 als Spieler, war dann bis 2004 hier, hat unter anderem mal zwischendurch mal in China ein halbes Jahr, als es noch gar nicht so gab, aber er sagte, die hätten damals ganz gut gezahlt schon. Aber er war auf jeden Fall lange hier, war dann im Verein Teammanager, war Assistent der Geschäftsführung, Jugendtrainer, er war alles. Er hat quasi so ein bisschen seine Funktionärskarriere hier gestartet, ist dann ja auch mit der Spielfahrung aufgestiegen 2012, ist danach dann weg, war dann bei St. Pauli und Düsseldorf und kam 2017 wieder als Sportdirektor damals und hat dann 2018 nach dem Helmut-Hack-Ernahme, der vielleicht auch manchen was sagt, quasi in den Ruhestand gegangen ist, danach hat dann Regge Susi als Sportgeschäftsführer übernommen. Also er war schon mal sehr lange da und jetzt hat er auch seit 2017 oder seit 2018 eigentlich immer in der Verantwortung und man kann ja sagen, das war in den letzten Jahren nicht sonderlich schlecht. Also hätte es schon mal schlimmer sein können. Jan Lukas schickt Luftballons für alle, die es nicht hören können.
Es ist Apple. Könnt ihr später drauf schütten. Es gibt einen Special-Effekt zum Rasenfunk für Rashida Sousi.
Aber das eine ist Rashida Sousi, vielleicht ganz kurz nur. Er hat dann auch Alexander Zorniger geholt, natürlich in der Verantwortung, in der er war. Vielleicht können wir so einfach einsteigen, ganz kurz, um den Rückblick für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer noch mal zu machen. Nämlich 2022. Fürth war ja abgestiegen aus der Bundesliga. Jan Lukas kennt es auch im 1. FC Köln, aber wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen öfter als Fürth. Man war abgestiegen, Stefan Leitel war dann weg, ist zu Hannover gegangen, also in der 2. Liga hängt alles mit allem zusammen. Und dann hat Marc Schneider übernommen, damals ein junger Schweizer Trainer, der nicht wirklich zurechtkam. Und dann hat man Alexander Zornäger geholt im Oktober 2022. War auf Platz 18 damals, Zornäger hat die ersten vier Spiele, 10 Punkte geholt, da war man schon lange nicht mal hinten. Eva, du weißt es noch, eines der ersten Spiele war gegen Aminia Bielefeld, das man gewonnen hat, 18 gegen 17, glaube ich. Und man hat dann den Klassenerhalt auch sehr souverän geschafft unter Zornäger. Hatte damals schon immer wieder komische Spiele drin. Er hat immer das Wort Abfall-Level geprägt, Zornäger. Das Abfall-Level sei zu stark. Abfall ist für mich Müll, aber er hat immer das Abfall-Level geprägt. Und da hat er eben auch nach seiner ersten Saison gesagt, das Abfall-Level dürfe nicht mehr so stark sein. Es müsste jetzt konstanter. Auch das ein Wort, das schon oft gefallen ist, heute müsste konstanter werden. Und das Abfall-Level wurde aber in der vergangenen Saison immer schlimmer. Denn man war– auch das, Gott sei Dank, im Jahr 2024– man ist mit zwei Siegen in dieses Jahr gestartet gegen Paderborn, das war die Session als Urbexspiel, das ich vorhin genannt habe, und gegen Heustern Kiel. Und dann war man Tabellen-Zweiter. Also Fürth war auf Aufstiegskurs. Danach hat man aber in sieben Spielen nur eins gewonnen und sechs davon verloren. Das heißt, es war eine stetige Achterbahnfahrt nach oben und nach unten. Am Ende ist man jetzt dann Achter geworden vergangenen Saison. Also für Fürth ist das okay. Es heißt immer so, etat der Bälle ist man zwölfter, dreizehter Platz. Insofern hat man ja überperformt und man hat in den letzten Jahren auch überperformt. Man ist ja angeblich in Corona-Zeiten mit einem Meta von 8,5 Millionen. Das war damals angeblich der zweitgeringste in Fürth. Also das geht auch. Man war damals auch mit Stefan Leitl. Als alle Hannoveranerinnen und Hannoveraner dürfen sich freuen. Ja, und in der letzten Saison war es aber halt auch so, dass man einfach extrem gute Spieler hatte. Und das waren halt leider, bis auf Armindo Sieb, nur Leihspieler. Dann hatte Jonas Urbeck im Tor, damit ein der besten Zweitligatoreiter. Man hatte Armindo Sieb, der im Saison davor kam, der zwölf Tore gemacht hat, war so in der Breakout-Saison. Jetzt spielt er in Mainz auch immer wieder in der Bundesliga, hat auch schon seine Tore da gemacht. Man hatte Robert Wagner vom SC Freiburg geliehen, der eigentlich als Achter kam und dann aber einen Sechser gegeben hat, weil der eigentliche Königstransfer, Orestis Kiumozoglu, wer sich vielleicht erinnert, ich habe den Namen schon mal gedroppt hier in der früheren Folge, der ist dann jetzt ganz spät noch gegen Ende der Transferphase zu Wehen, Wiesbaden gewechselt und da ist er jetzt auch seit ein paar Spielen nur noch auf der Bank. Also das war der Königstransfer. Naja, wirft ein schlaglicher Kaderplanung, aber man kann da immer richtig liegen. Und da Robert Wagner hatte man auch, der dann eben einen starken Sechser in diesem 3-4-1-2 gespielt hat hinter Julian Green, also es war eine sehr spielstarke, aber auch kämpferisch starke Mittelfeldzentrale. Und man hatte Tim Lämpere. Und wer weiß, dass Alexander Zorniger eigentlich gerne einen intensiven Fußball spielen will, das hat er in jedem Satz, glaube ich, erwähnt, und einen sehr pressigen, intensiven Fußball spielen will, da war Tim Lämpere der perfekte Spieler dafür. Also er hat immer gesagt, Tim Lämpere gibt dir aus dem Stand einfach 35 bis 40 Sprints pro Spiel. Und ich habe es mal verglichen, als Dennis Sabeni gespielt hat, hat er einmal 13 oder 14 Sprints in dem Spiel. Und das ist natürlich ein krasser Unterschied. Es sind unterschiedliche Spielertypen, da ist es kein Sabeni-Bashing. Aber diese Sprints haben dann eben einfach gefehlt in dieser Saison, weil man es auch nicht geschafft hat, diese Spielertypen adäquat zu ersetzen. Also Sieb und Lämpere sind gegangen. Sieb hat man ja aufgrund einer Rückkauf-Option des FC Bayern für 1,5 Millionen verloren bei einem korrektierten Marktwert von 4 Millionen. Auch nicht so gut. Also für Fürth ist immer auf Transferlöse angewiesen. Ist auch schlecht. Und ansonsten hat man halt im Sturm vor allem dann Noel Futkoi geholt. Eintracht Frankfurt-Fans kennen ihn. Ebti Saarbrücken-Fans kennen ihn. Fliegt aus dem Pokal, weil er Marcel Gauz in den Hintern getreten hat im Pokalspiel. Weshalb er drei Pokalspiele gesperrt hat und bislang bei beiden Pokalspielen der Spielvereinigung nicht mitspielen durfte. Und es kommt ja kein weiteres Mal hinzu. Das heißt, er ist auch in der nächsten Saison noch im Pokal gesperrt. Ja, den hat man geholt. Das ist für mich aber so vom Spielertypen eher der Ersatz für Sieb gewesen. So ein dripler, abschlussstärker Spieler. Aber diesen laufstarken Spieler wie Lempeler hat man einfach nicht geholt. Man hat dann sehr spät in der Sommervorbereitung noch zwei Spieler ausgeliehen. Hat nämlich Marlon Mustapha auch da wieder. Letztes Jahr in Düsseldorf. Den hat man geholt, der aber noch gar keinen Bein auf den Boden bringt, als er im Pokal gegen den Fünf-Ligisten einen Tor geschossen hat in der ersten Runde. Sonst aber gar nicht. Er hat letztens mal eine halbe Stunde gespielt. Und ich habe keine gelungene Aktion von ihm gesehen, leider. Und am Deadline Day war so eine Notleihe. Da hat man auch noch eine Manja Motika ausgeliehen für die Offensive, der jetzt am vergangenen Wochenende gegen Darmstadt zum ersten Mal in der Startelf stand, das da zum ersten Mal ganz okay gemacht hat. Aber auch das keine wirklichen Verstärkungen. Das ist natürlich dann schon schwierig. Auch die sechste Position war sehr lange unbesetzt in der Sommerpause, was auch nicht gut ist, wenn man sich einspielen muss. Man wusste eigentlich, dass Robert Wagner zurückgeht zum SC Freiburg und dann wieder ausgeliehen wird zum FC St. Pauli. Aber man wusste relativ früh, dass er auch gehen wird. Und dann hat es halt sehr, sehr, sehr lange gedauert. Und man hat dann erst Ende August mit Sacha Boncet von Standard Lüttich in den 6er nach verpflichtet. Und in den ersten Spieltagen hat er mit Philipp Müller an Eigengewächs gespielt, seine ersten Zweite-Liga-Minuten gesammelt. Bittere Ironie zum Nachhinein. Die Punkteausbeute war deutlich besser mit dem 20-Jährigen aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs, als mit dem Spieler, den man von Standard Lüttich verpflichtet hat. Denn seit Boncet da ist, hat man halt nur noch ein Spiel gewonnen. Neun, zwei, ein und halb. Er hat Halbzeit in Regensburg noch gespielt. Aber zumindest war es unter Philipp Müller deutlich erfolgreicher. Da sind wir jetzt auch schon beim Punkt. Denn Fürth war am Anfang der Saison erfolgreich. Man hat gegen Brösen Münster gewonnen. Hat danach auch Betzenberg sehr lange geführt. Was ja auch nicht so ein einfaches Pflaster ist in der 2. Liga. Hätte da fast gewonnen, hat dann den Sieg noch später aus der Hand gegeben. Aber man war sehr erfolgreich. Man ist im Pokal weitergekommen, was in Fürth auch immer ein großes Thema ist. Man scheiterte gerne auch in der ersten Runde aus. Insofern lief das alles sehr, sehr gut. Und dann gab es noch ein Heimspiel gegen den SC Paderborn. Und da kann sich vielleicht manche und manche daran erinnern, dass Nahuel Noll, der designierte Urbeck-Nachfolger, ein weiteres großes Torhütertalent von der TSG Hoffenheim, ein Fehler unterlaufen ist. Und ein Fehler ist auch Alexander Zorniger unterlaufen, der einen Fehler zum Gegentor geführt hat. Alexander Zorniger hat dann ja Nahuel Noll in der Luft zerrissen. Ich meine, das war auch hier im Rasenfunk Kurz, zumindest mal Thema. Aber dieses Sky-Interview war wirklich, es war ja krass und Zorniger mussten sich danach entschuldigen, auch auf offiziellen Vereinskanälen dafür. Für mich war das im Nachhinein der Anfang vom Ende von Zorniger, weil er den jungen Spieler komplett abgekanzelt hat, wenn man noch über Vertrauen spricht bei jungen Spielern. Noll war ein extrem starker Rückhalt. Es war von Anfang an klar, dass er die Nummer 1 sein wird. Er war ein guter Torhüter, auch für dieses Alter extrem ruhig gespielt. Dann ist jemand einen Fehler unterlaufen, was damals Zorniger erklärt hat damit, dass er schon öfter gesagt hat, dass er nicht so lange warten soll mit dem Fußballball. Aber das ist ein 20-jähriger Torhüter. Dafür hat er schon echt gut gemacht. Das war leider ein Fehler, der zum Gegentor gefühlt hat, dass er nicht gewonnen hat gegen Paderborn. Da hat er ihn aber so zerrissen in der Luft, dass er das Wort der jungen Spritzer fiel, den ich zuhören können und was auch immer. Zorniger war ja immer sehr direkt in seiner Ansprache. Das war nicht das erste Mal, dass er in PKs schon unterschiedlich nuanciert, aber immer wieder Spieler angegriffen gefühlt hat. Jeden außer Brandi Maregotta und Trulling Green mal irgendwo zerlegt in der PK. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass so etwas in einer Mannschaft, in einer funktionierenden Mannschaft, nicht wirklich gut ankommt. Das ist natürlich alles eine Mutmaßung, der darüber spricht, keine Offen. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass die Mannschaft für diesen Trainer gebrannt hat und für ihn durchs Feuer gegangen ist, um diese abgestoschten Formulierungen zu nehmen. Jan Lukas, du möchtest was dazu sagen. Ich rede schon so lange.
Ich habe eine Frage vor allem. Ja, das hatte ich am Anfang auch bei der MFC. Man hört das ja beim Sonniger immer wieder. Man kennt es ja auch noch aus Stuttgart, als sie da diesen Affenjubel gemacht haben, nachdem sie als wilder Affen bezeichnet wurden. Wo die Spieler dann beim Torjubel durch sind. Ich meine, es wäre Sonniger gewesen. Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher. Auf jeden Fall war immer schon dieses Bild, dass die Spieler öffentlich nicht unbedingt angegangen werden, aber dass es fragwürdig war. War das in der letzten Saison, die ja ganz gut lief, auch so? Weil da hatte ich eher das Gefühl auch mit Urbeck und Lämpere, wo die Ligen ganz gut funktioniert haben. Sieb hast du angesprochen. Das waren ja schon Junge. Da dachte ich, das ist ja schon jemand, der guten Fußball spielen lässt, der auch eine junge Einheit beschwören kann. Wagner fand ich auch damals immer herausragend, was auch ein bisschen erklärt, warum es jetzt irgendwie viel fehlt. Das hat er schon gut dargestellt. War das denn da auch so, oder ist es mehr so, dass wenn es schlecht läuft, dann schützt man sich so?
Es war schon so, dass da auch Spiele teilweise öffentlich abgekancelt wurden. Es waren aber andere. Die haben ja funktioniert. Die wurden dann auch sehr selten öffentlich schlecht geredet. Natürlich ist es ein Misserfolg eher. Ich habe auch mal das rückblicklich immer witzig, was man als Sportjournalist alles macht. Nach den ersten 100 Tagen oder so habe ich ein Porträt geschrieben mit der Überschrift von Wegen Angry Zorniger. Dieser Mann war so verschrien. Es gab ja auch dieses Twitter-Profil Angry Zorniger aus Stuttgart. Der war ja so ein ganz böser Menschenfresser. Martin, den ich in den vierten Anfangen erlebt habe, war ein extrem herzlicher Mensch. Er war auch bis zuletzt bei vielen Fans sehr beliebt, weil er sehr nahbar war. Er war unterwegs, teilweise vorletzte Saison war er so früh shoppen in der Stadt, da waren dann Fans unterwegs. Dann hat er sich mit an den Tisch gesetzt beim Frühstücken und so. Es gibt halt wenige Trainer, die so etwas machen. Er hat ja auch mal betont, dass er sich im Verein immer komplett verschreibt. Das hat er auch gemacht hier in Fürth, aber irgendwie so mit dem schleichenden Misserfolgen, vielleicht auch mit der Erkenntnis, dass er hier in Fürth jetzt nicht erfolgreich– also erfolgreich war er ja, aber nicht so erfolgreich, wie er das sein will sein kann, nämlich aufsteigen. Er hat immer gesagt, er ist stärker darin, in Fürth etwas zu spielen, als gegen etwas zu spielen. Das hat er immer impliziert. Er will um den Aufstieg spielen und nicht gegen den Abstieg. Und er hat irgendwann gemerkt, es geht nicht in Fürth, weil die erstens mal entweder Spieler sehr spät kommen oder Spieler, du weißt, dass sie nach einem Jahr wieder weg sind. Und da hat es sich sehr geändert. Er wurde ja auch immer pragmatischer und dann auch immer völlig sturer mit der Zeit und leider halt dann auch immer öfter ausfällig. Also es war teilweise mir gegenüber so. Ich kann damit klarkommen. Ich bin kein Fußballer unter ihm, aber auch gegenüber Spielern. Also es war so ein schleichender Prozess, ein bisschen abgebaut hat. Und was Jan Lukas vorhin sagte, es gibt eine Doppelpass-Sekuenz von 2000. Wann war Sonneke dort? Vor acht Jahren, glaube ich. 2016 oder so. 15, 16. Da wird darüber debattiert. Debattiert? Ein schwieriges Wort für einen Franken. Wenn das T und das D immer gleich sind. Da wird darüber gesprochen, warum Sonneke gescheitert ist in Stuttgart. Und das sind einfach eins zu eins die gleichen Dinge, dass er die Defensive nicht in den Griff bekommen hat, dass er über junge Spieler geschimpft hat. Damals war es unter anderem auch Timo Werner, den er dann sehr, sehr stark öffentlich beleidigt hat. Ja, das waren erstaunliche Parallelen. Und das ist natürlich krass, wenn ein Trainer acht Jahre später, man denkt, er wäre gereift, aber in ihm drin ist dann doch noch irgendwie was, was immer wieder rausbricht. Und man hat es dann auch gesehen, um da fliegend aufs Aktuelle auch zu kommen, dass es dann irgendwann nicht mehr funktioniert. Ja, weil das Pressing hat nicht funktioniert. Man hat diesen Spielertypen nicht. Er hat den Braunschweig damals dann Marlon Mustafa spielen lassen, um so eine Lämpale-Rolle zu spielen. Man wollte bewusst Braunschweig hoch anlaufen. Und Marlon Mustafa war dann der langsamste Spieler auf dem Platz, ist nie angelaufen und wurde zur Halbzeit ausgewechselt. Das kann natürlich so ein Trainer auch nerven, wenn man eigentlich weiß, dass es schon mal funktioniert hat. Und es hat ihn offenbar so sehr enttäuscht, dass er– das ist mittlerweile mehrfach korrektiert worden, und ich weiß es auch aus sicherer Quelle– dass es so war bei der Videoanalyse nach dem Derby. Also bei seiner letzten Videoanalyse in Fürth hat er Szenen vorgespielt von den Spielgängern wie in der Bielefeld damals, Eva. Weil da war er ja nur vier Tage im Amt und hat gesagt, seht was möglich ist, wenn ihr so spielt, wie ich das will. Und warum macht ihr es denn nicht, dass ihr so spielt, wie ich es will?
Ich möchte dazu sagen, ich glaube, es hat auch mehr damit zu tun, dass Amina Bielefeld zu dem Zeitpunkt schon abgestiegen war.
Das war ja der Hinrunde.
Ja, aber wir haben uns da nicht mehr rausgerettet, wenn ich kurz dran erinnere, an welcher Liga dieser Verein momentan spielt. Aber sorry dafür. Aber weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das auch so das perfekte Beispiel ist.
Ja, aber tatsächlich war es damals schon krass zu sehen, wie eine Mannschaft, die extrem verunsichert war in der 2. Liga, die Tabellenletzter, war die gerade in Heidenheim verloren hat, dem Interimstrainer damals. Wie die halt einfach plötzlich aufspielt und dann zehn Punkte in vier Spielen holt und aussieht wie eine Zornige Mannschaft, die ein halbes Jahr lang trainiert hat. Und ich glaube, dass das auch er ist ein extrem selbstbewusster Mensch, dass sie das schon auch in seiner Ehre ein bisschen gekränkt hat, dass es halt plötzlich gar nicht mehr so lief. Er hat dann auch immer pragmatischer gespielt. Pressing hat man teilweise gar nicht mehr gesehen. Dann haben sie halt im Mittelfeld ein bisschen gepresst, hat aber auch nicht wirklich funktioniert. Die Ergebnisse waren dann auch nach dieser ersten Länderspielpause entsprechend. Man hat dann nämlich einfach nicht mehr gewonnen für ein Spiel lang. Dann war dieses Derby gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg. Ich möchte noch mal so ausführlich darüber reden. Der 1. FC Nürnberg kam da ja auch nicht mit sonderlich viel Selbstbewusstsein. Der sah halt einfach aus wie Prime Barcelona in diesem Spiel. Das war wirklich krass zu sehen, weil die Fürther einfach auch– also gar nichts. Das hat nicht funktioniert in diesem Spiel. Das war ja vor knapp zwei Wochen. Also der Spieltag war vor zwei Wochen am Wochenende. Und dann habe ich nach dem Spiel lang mit Rasen Dasusi gesprochen, weil das sind die typischen Mechanismen. Man kennt sie. Was ist mit dem Trainer jetzt? Fünf Spiele sieglos. Irgendwie funktioniert es gar nicht mehr. 0-4 im Derby. Nach 1970 war das letzte Mal, dass man den Derby 0-4 zu Hause verloren hatte. Also schon ein bisschen her. Und da hat Asusi aber gleich gesagt, ne ne, da diskutieren wir gar nicht drüber. Und der Zorniger bleibt auf jeden Fall unser Trainer. Zwei Tage später war dann der Zorniger weg und war der Asusi weg. Und es wurde erklärt, man wollte einen sportlichen Neuanfang unbedingt starten und das hat man für notwendig befunden. Der Aufsichtsrat hat das wohl auch nicht befunden, denn der Aufsichtsrat kann ja nur einen Geschäftsführer entlassen. Aber Holger Schwiewagner, der kaufmännische Geschäftsführer, den heißt, den kennt ihr wahrscheinlich die wenigsten, aber der war das schon noch, hat das selbst betont, auch treibende Kraft dahinter, dem Aufsichtsrat vielleicht auch nahezulegen, dass es notwendig wäre, einen Neuanfang zu starten. Und das war natürlich auch, lag daran, dass Asusi einfach ganz klar an Zornigga festgehalten hat. Er hätte auch weiter festgehalten, das weiß ich sicher. Und dann war es ein bisschen wie Nürnberg, da musste damals auch ein Sportvorstand gehen, damit der Trainer geht, weil der Sportvorstand den Trainer nicht entlassen wollte. Insofern war das ähnlich. Man kannte natürlich auch die Kaderplanung in Fürth in dieser Saison, aber auch in der Bundesliga war die Kaderplanung nicht ausreichend, da ist man ja auch sang und klanglos abgestiegen. Das sind alles Dinge, die man Asusi angreiten kann. Aber, ja, ich weiß nicht. Also jetzt mitten in der Saison, quasi die beiden sportlichen Gesichter, das waren ja wirklich die Gesichter dieses Vereins. Herauszuwerfen zwei Männer, die ihre Erfahrung im Umgang mit Krisen haben. Das ist ja auch immer vielleicht gut, in so einer Krise jemanden zu haben, der vielleicht ein bisschen Druck von der Mannschaft nimmt. Jetzt hat man, wie du vorhin sagtest, Stefan Fürstner, Ex-Profi, Braunschweig Mainz, auch für, der vor zwei Jahren als Trainee ins Nachwuchsleistungszentrum erst kam, der jetzt in diesem Sommer aufgerückt ist als Leiter des Nachwuchsleistungszentrums. Aber jemand, der ja keinerlei Erfahrung auf dieser Position hat, als Sportvorstand, Sportdirektor, als sportliches Gesicht der Mannschaft, wurde das öffentlich tituliert und mit Leo Haas, einem Trainer, von dem ich sehr viel halte, der auch einen guten Weg hat. Also der hat damals in Fürth auch gespielt, war dann auch in Ingolstadt und Rostock, bilde ich mir ein, hat da gespielt und hat dann eben seine Trainer-Kehre ganz unten angefangen. Also ein bisschen so Hürzeler-Wipes. Ich fand auch das Gespräch mit ihm sehr, sehr gut. Im Sommer hat er die Fürth U23 übernommen. Vorher hatte er unter anderem Tintiers vor Wasserburg, den kennen wir schon nicht. Er hat die Menschen, die aus Bayern kommen, trainiert. Aber dann hat er fünfmal in Folge zum Aufstieg geführt bis in die Bayern-Liga. Das ist die fünfte höchste Liga, also die Oberliga. Dann hat er Wackelburg-Hausen zweimal gut in der Regionalliga Bayern trainiert. Die wurden damals dritter. Er war jetzt Trainer bei der U18 von RB Salzburg. Er ist auch ein Trainer, der viel Erfahrung trotzdem mit seinem jungen Alters schon hat. Und ich glaube, das könnte auch gut werden. Aber es ist halt sehr undankbar, in der englischen Woche zu starten, starten zu müssen, ohne viel Trainingszeit mit einer Mannschaft, die für uns sicher ist. Und ja, jetzt hat er halt diesen Makel, so war es auch im Boulevard schon, Haas hat erst zwei seiner drei Spiele verloren. Weil er hat halt schon drei Spiele innerhalb einer Woche. Das ist halt bitter als Interimstrainer. Jetzt hat man diese Misere. Und mal sehen.
Ja, mir ist aufgefallen, ich glaube, so das Erste, was ja einfach rein, wenn man einfach draufguckt, auf die Ausstellung, er hat ja, glaube ich, auf Viererkette umgestellt. Also in der Zorniga war ja meistens eigentlich immer 3-H-5er-Kette oder beziehungsweise 3-H-5er-Kette. Und ich meine, klar, also wie du schon sagst, so eine verunsicherte Mannschaft, ich glaube nicht, dass man jetzt auf dieses System direkt sagen kann, okay, damit hat man jetzt aber irgendwie neugierige Gegentore kassiert in drei Spieltagen. Das funktioniert schon mal nicht. Sondern es ist ja, also wie du schon sagst, ja durchaus doppelt undankbar. Also sowohl ist es ja nicht sein Kader, der, der für den Kader verantwortlich ist, ist auch nicht mehr da. Also diese Mannschaft ist verunsichert und die Defensive, die kriegst du auch nicht mal eben zusammen. Und es ist ja glaube ich auch noch so, hattest du im Vorgespräch auch geschrieben, Fürth hätte sogar noch mehr Gegentore kassieren müssen. Deutlich mehr. Deutlich mehr. Also am deutlichsten mehr. Ich habe es auch nochmal rausgesucht, hätte Hannover kassieren müssen. Die müssten nämlich stand jetzt eigentlich fast acht Gegentore mehr haben. Das ist schon absurd, wenn wir eben über die Defensive gesprochen haben. Aber ich finde es halt so schwierig, weil da kommen so viele Dinge zusammen. Jetzt hat er sich, glaube ich, auch noch unbeliebt gemacht. So ein bisschen, weil er, glaube ich, sich etwas unglücklich auf der Pressekonferenz vor dem Darmstadt-Spiel geäußert hat, im Sinne von, ja, hier bitte nicht nur bei Siegen feiern und bei Niederlagen ausfeifen. Führte dann, glaube ich, auch zu einem Stimmungsbalkott auf jeden Fall irgendwann im Darmstadt-Spiel.
Also nicht wegen dieser PK, dieser Stimmungsbalkott natürlich, aber es kam jetzt nicht sonderlich gut an, weil jeder kennt ja Fürth und kennt die Fürther-Fanszene. Die ist nicht sonderlich groß und das sind aber halt über 1000 Menschen nach Schalke gefahren. Das waren über 3000 in Regensburg beim Pokalspiel und die haben da dauerhaft gesungen. Und dann wurde natürlich nach diesem Pokal aus, aufgrund der angestauten Boot, kann man ja auch verstehen, diese Derby-Niederlage war schon krass für Fürth. Also viele Menschen in meinem Alter oder jünger haben es eben nie erlebt, dass man ein Derby so hoch verloren hat. Und seit 1970, da waren einige Menschen nicht geboren, die im Stadion waren. Und da hat diese Abfolge der ganzen Dinge, dann Pokalspiele in Fürth sind eh schon heikel, weil man gefühlt jedes Jahr schallt in der ersten oder in der zweiten Runde. Man hat zuletzt 2018 ein Pokalheimspiel und das war, weil man Platz 15 war und dadurch in der ersten Runde ein Heimspiel hatte. Und dann ist man auch ausgeschieden gegen Borussia Dortmund. Ja, und das ist natürlich dann bitter. Und dann wurde in Regensburg gepfiffen, ja, auch so laut wie ich selten erlebt habe in Fürth. Und da merkt man dann die Unerfahrenheit eines Trainers in solchen Situationen, dann sagt man sowas halt einfach nicht. Also ein erfahrener Trainer hätte das nicht gesagt. Nicht pfeifen, weil es war für ihn einfach eindrücklich, weil bei seinem zweiten Spieler halt extrem laut gepfiffen wurde. Und er kann nichts dafür, für alles, was vorher war. Er kann nichts für den Pokal aus. Vor einem Jahr gegen vierteligsten FC Homburg, vor zwei Jahren gegen fünftelige Stuttgarter Kickers, da kann er nichts dafür. Aber die Menschen in Fürth sind halt einfach irgendwann auch genervt, dass sie hören, jedes Jahr man hat kein Geld und dann schenkt man jedes Jahr mindestens 800.000 Euro oder mehr her. Das würde ja kumuliert dann auch irgendwann mal zwei Millionen ergeben, bei denen man mal einen Spieler halten könnte, womöglich oder einen Spieler verpflichten könnte. Und muss ich mal sagen, wir müssen jetzt noch von der berühmten Reste Ramperspieler verpflichten, weil wir haben kein Geld. Da ist halt viel zusammengekommen. Und wie gesagt, das war undankbar. Und klar, dieses Spiel gegen Darmstadt, das war der absolut, das Witzige war, wir hatten eine Podcast-Folge, die hieß Tiefpunkt. Und dann haben wir den Tiefpunkt des Tiefpunkts gesucht. Und ich bin ein bisschen in Marianne-Graben bei der Recherche abgestiegen, um zu schauen, was der wirkliche Tiefpunkt der Welt ist. Der Tiefpunkt war auf jeden Fall dieses Spiel gegen Darmstadt. Deswegen wirkt die Mannschaft wirklich tot in diesem Spiel. Du hast vorhin gesagt, jetzt fünf Gegentore davor gegen Nürnberg, vier auf Schalke, drei gegen extrem verunsicherte Schalker. Man hätte 25 bis 27 Tore kassieren müssen, hat jetzt aber auch 22 kassiert. Es hat ein bisschen auch so drüber hinweg getäuscht unter der Saison, denn man hat schon die ganzen Saisonprobleme mit der Defensive. Am ersten Spieltag hatte Preußen Münster schon über drei Expected Goals entführt, aber dann war die individuelle Qualität nicht so hoch, dass die drei Tore gemacht haben. Deshalb hat man 3-1 gewonnen. Zwischenzeitlich hat man mal eine Differenz zwischen XG und den realen Toren von 10. Und da weiß ja jeder, der ein bisschen sich mit Statistik auskennt, dass es da die berühmte Regression zur Mitte gibt, die ja auch im Rasenfunk schon oft genannt wurde. Und ich habe diese Regression zur Mitte sogar im Podcast und glaube ich auch in der PK mal angesprochen. Und dann hieß es immer, wir hätten sie ja nicht kassiert, hat Alexander Zorniger gesagt. Das war seine Erklärung, man habe die Tore ja nicht kassiert. Ich habe dann mal gesagt, man wird sie aber irgendwann kassieren und ich will kein Klugscheißer sein, aber man kassiert sie halt jetzt regelmäßig. Man hat ja schon vor dem Derby immer drei Spiele lang immer zwei Tore kassiert und man weiß ja, in der 2. Liga steigt man oft halt einfach auch auf, wenn man wie an U-96 öfter mal 1-0 oder 2-1 gewinnt und nicht wenn man öfter mal 2-2 spielt oder halt 1-5 verliert. Insofern ist eine gute Defensive schon sehr wichtig und das Krasse ist ja auch, diese Mannschaft ist in der Defensive nicht komplett neu zusammengestellt. Und letztes Jahr hat Fürth mal fünf Spiele in Folge zu Null gespielt unter Zorniger, auch mal in der Hinrunde. Also es gab fünf, ich glaube vier Siege an Unentschieden oder fünf Siege. Zumindest gab es fünf Spiele zu Null. Also und davon sind noch viele da. Luca Eder ist noch da, Marco Maio ist da, Simon Astor, Gideon Jung. Also es sind ja alle Spiele, die letztes Jahr auch schon da waren. Auch da, wenn Michael Zorniger gar keine Rolle mehr gespielt hat, obwohl er mal zwischenzeitlich der beste 2. Liga-Verteidiger war. Ja, also die können es eigentlich, aber irgendwie wirkt alles seltsam gelähmt. Das war auch die Formulierung von Stefan Fürster nach dem Schalke-Spiel, nach dem Darmstadt-Spiel, dass alles seltsam gelähmt wirkt. Und natürlich ist es schwierig, als eine gelähmte Mannschaft, die jetzt auch schon diese ganzen, ja trotzdem einige Misserfolge der letzten Jahre erlebt hat, da waren viele in der Bundesliga auch dabei, die haben den Bundesliga-Abstieg mitgemacht. Die haben dieses krasse erste Jahr nach dem Bundesliga-Abstieg in der 2. Liga mitgemacht, letztes Jahr diese Achterbahnfahrt. Deswegen glaube ich auch, dass es für Fürth vor allem darum geht, diese Saison jetzt irgendwie zu retten. Man wird dann, glaube ich, nicht oben mitspielen, dafür ist die Kaderqualität auch nicht ausreichend. Man darf nicht absteigen, also weil das ist für Fürth tödlich, weil man halt sehr stark auf Fernsehgelder angewiesen ist, noch mehr als andere Vereine und dann ist viel schon mal die Formulierung, zwei Jahre in der 3. Liga hält man aus, mehr ist schwierig, weil halt der Verein einfach sonst keine großen Einnahmen hat und darum geht es. Und dann glaube ich, geht es einfach darum, auch dann das wirklich zu resetten, den Reset-Knopf, den berühmten Fußball zu drücken, weil es laufen die Verträge nahezu aller Spieler in der Defensive aus und das wäre ja ein Ansatzpunkt, da vielleicht nicht alle zu verlängern, sondern auch mal die berühmte Blutauffrischung. Vielleicht wollen wir mit diesen Fußball-Phrasen um mich und Schloss gehen, aber einfach da auch mal wieder dafür zu sorgen, dass da einfach andere Spielertypen auch sind, die nicht diese letzten drei Jahre miterlebt haben, sondern auch mal Spieler. Andere, Verteidigungsmonster, hat Alexander Zondelger, Marc Sack, die habe man nicht in Fürth. Vielleicht braucht man mal Verteidigungsmonster, wenn man halt nicht verteidigen kann.
Ja, ganz kurze Frage noch zum Abschluss. Ich weiß, das ist ein bisschen gemein. Aber wie geht es denn sonst für dich jetzt weiter? Also hat Leo Haas die nötige Lizenz, um da auch Chef-Trainer zu sein? Michi nickt für alle, die es nicht sehen können. Aber ist es, also du scheinst ja sonst, du hast eben schon gesagt, du findest ihn sonst einen sehr interessanten Trainer. Also wäre das für dich auch jemand, der schafft, diese Warnschaft aus dieser Verunsicherung wieder rauszukommen? Also man muss ja sagen, zum Glück ist ja fast auch wieder Länderspielpause. Ich glaube, da freut sich Führt tatsächlich sehr besonders drauf, weil man einfach vielleicht auch einfach mal Wochenende kopffrei kriegen kann, so blöd, wie das auch klingt. Aber ist ja jetzt schon übel gewesen mit der englischen Woche. Jetzt geht es gegen Köln, wir wissen es alle jetzt. Dann zu Hause gegen Karlsruhe und aus jetzt gegen Ulm. Das ist jetzt auch einfach nicht das einfachste Programm, was jetzt auf einen wartet.
Da kommen ja noch weitere Spieler gegen Hannover und den HSV zum Beispiel. Also es kommt in Fürth schon ab und zu jetzt mal die Formulierung auf. Also zumindest von der Fan-Seite. Es wäre gut, noch einmal zu gewinnen. Mindestens irgendwie noch unentschieden, dass man so 17 Punkte zu Winterpause hat. Also weil natürlich ja es schwer vorstellbar ist, wie diese Hannover 690 in dieser Form, wie Fürth da gewinnen soll. Also noch dazu, das haben wir jetzt gar nicht besprochen. Fürth war unter Zornäcker auch vor allem sehr heimstark. Man war letztes Jahr 8. in der Tabelle, war aber halt in der Heimtabelle Platz 3. Man hat fast immer zu Hause gewonnen. Mittlerweile ist man Platz 15 in der Heimtabelle und hat einmal gewonnen und nur 5 Punkte geholt zu Hause. Das ist im Abstiegskampf auch schwierig, wenn man selbst zu Hause nicht mehr gewinnt. Aber weil du gerade die Länderspielpause angesprochen hast, ich bin gespannt, ob Leo Haas die bekommt. Wenn man jetzt in Köln wieder so untergeht, dann kann es natürlich auch sein, dass man sagt, man nutzt diese Länderspielpause für einen weiteren Reset. Dann muss man es ja fast machen. Wenn man jetzt in Köln wieder fünf Torekassee, was ja passieren kann bei der offensiven Bucht des FC, was, wenn Tim Lemberle alles an der Chance macht, auch passieren kann. Ich würde es Leo Haas gönnen. Du hast vorhin gefragt, er hat die notwendige Lizenz, er hat die Pro-Lizenz, ist Fußballlehrer, hat er auch gemacht. Wie gesagt, ein Trainer, der auch mehr Fußball spielen will. Ich bin mit Alexander Zorniger manchmal auch aneinander geraten, weil er immer gesagt hat, ich soll aufhören, immer über diesen Viertelflachpass zu reden. Das ist alles lang her. Zorniger war nicht unbedingt derjenige, der im Training auch extrem viel Wert auf gutes Fußballspiel gelegt hat, sondern das war halt immer in irgendeiner Form eine Simulation des Pressings und Gegenpressings. Und Leo Haas hat schon von Anfang an gesagt, er war früher Zehner, also der will Fußball spielen, hat Marz auf Schalke ja auch gesehen. Sie haben mehr Fußball gespielt. Da gab es eine eindrückliche Szene, dass Maxi Dietz, der Verteidiger, beim Abschluss weggelaufen ist von Nahuel Noll. Und dann wurde er zusammengeschissen vom Trainer, dass er gefälligst nach hinten laufen und den Pass fordern soll. Und dann haben sie flach aufgebaut von hinten. Und das als bekennender Freund des schönen Fußballspiels. Gefällt mir das natürlich, wenn ein Trainer mehr Fußball spielen will. Insofern finde ich es halt bitter, dass es gerade so blöd läuft. Man hat aber schon dieses Bemühen, mehr Fußball zu spielen gesehen. Gegen Schalke war das sehr erfolgreich. Klar, das lag auch um FC Schalke, der einfach gar nicht verteidigt hat in dem Spiel. Das ist auch krass. Wenn du gegen Fürth so aussiehst, in dieser Form, ist es schon besorgniserregend. Klar, wenn du als Fürth so aussiehst wie gegen Darmstadt, ist es auch besorgniserregend. Es hängt vieles von dem Spiel am Wochenende ab. Es wurde auch schon von Holger Schwiewackner gesagt, natürlich sondieren wir den Markt. Das heißt, das spricht für mich dafür, dass Leo Haas dieses Spiel bekommt. Es spricht keiner von Ultimatum. Wenn man jetzt 1 zu 2 knapp verliert und eine gute Leistung zeigt, dann kann es sein, dass er bleibt. Wenn man jetzt wieder erwartet, gewinnt er, bleibt er natürlich auf jeden Fall. Es wurde ja auch, das haben wir nicht gesagt, er verabredet bis Winter, dass er sicher Trainer bleibt. Auch das ist ja eine Formulierung, mit der man sich ein bisschen in die Bridulie gebracht hat. Denn man hätte ja sagen können, bis auf Weiteres machen andere ja auch. Also Jan Regensbock war Interimstrainer. Paz heißt er, glaube ich. Wir haben ja auch gesagt, bis auf Weiteres ist er Trainer. Und den Führer hat man gesagt, nein, der bleibt erst mal bis zum Winter. Das waren halt acht Spiele bis zum Winter und acht auch richtungsweisende Spiele. Insofern muss man jetzt gerade ein bisschen so rumlavieren, um dieses, na ja, schauen wir mal, was die Länderspielpause und so weiter. Aber wie gesagt, wenn es einigermaßen gut geht in Köln, bleibt er und ansonsten kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es auch leider wieder zu Ende geht, auch wenn ich ihn als Mensch sehr sympathisch finde als Trainer, seine fußballerische Idee gut finde. Und auch die U23, die er vorher in Fürth ja trainiert hatte, die war auch sehr erfolgreich. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dann so einfach geht, dass er wieder zurückgeht. Das wäre dann auch für einen Trainer, der schon mal in der 2. Liga war, vielleicht nicht dankbar. Aber er ist ja hier unter Vertrag, insofern wird er die 2. Mannschaft wieder übernehmen. Aber wenn ich einen Wunsch äußern darf, geht sein Wochenende-Flitz unentschieden aus. 1 zu 1, so ein ganz biederes 1 zu 1. Und Fürth sagt, wir behalten ein Leo Haas-Fest. Er bekommt die Letterspielpause. Und dann in der Rückrunde spielt Fürth 1 auf.
Ja, sonst sage ich an der Stelle schon mal Finger weg von Mitch Kniart. Bielefeld ist nämlich die defensiv stärkste Mannschaft der Welt.
Der Name fiel in Fürth schon mal, Eva.
Weißt du was, Michi? Bis jetzt war ich glücklich.
Tatsächlich, weil Michael Mutzel, der in Bielefeld ja auch in der sportlichen Verantwortung ist, auch schon mal in der sportlichen Verantwortung war. Deswegen habe ich diesen Namen mitgekniert. Mehrfach gehört nicht nur aus deinem Munde.
Ja, Mensch.
Aber Fürth hat kein Geld, um einen Trainer rauszukaufen. Insofern ist ja alles gut.
Ich würde sagen, Bielefeld nimmt es im Zweifel auch. Aber wir sind ja im Gegensatz zu euch in der dritten Pokalrunde. Von daher brauchen wir die 1,3 Millionen. Nein, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht nicht so unbedingt. Aber bevor mir jetzt zu einem handfesten Streit ausbricht, das Jan Lukas und Michi hier schon klären wollen, wer am Wochenende gewinnt am Podcast-Tisch, würde ich euch erstmal beiden danken, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid. Ich gefühlt habe mir mehr über alle Thematiken neben dem Platz gesprochen als auf dem Platz. Oder zumindest ein solides 50-50. Vielen Dank dafür, Jan Lukas, dass du uns das so berichtet hast vorm FC.
Ja, sehr, sehr gerne.
Und natürlich auch lieben Dank an Michi Fischer. Ich verspreche dir nächstes Mal, bis du hier. Da führt es bestimmt wieder besser. Ich mache heute sehr viele Versprechungen. Ich sollte das nicht bleiben lassen.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt. Aber danke dir, Eva.
Und dann auch noch zum Schluss ein ganz, ganz schnelles Housekeeping. Und zwar bedanke ich mich noch stellvertretend bei Florian Turburis, L2X, Thomas Marx und Felix Kress für eure Unterstützung im Rasenfunk. Und ich habe euch noch einen Artikel von der Sportschau zum Thema Fußballvereiner auf X in den Show notes verlinkt. Und sonst verabschiede ich mich. Wir hören uns. Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.